وثائق تتسرب من داخل اروقه البنتاغون يسمع
صداها في موسكو الوثائق المسربه تزعم وجود
خلافات مستعره داخل اروقه الحكم الروسي
تقول الوثائق ان اقتتالا يبدو اعمق مما
عليه بين المخابرات الروسيه ووزاره الدفاع
وبحسب التسريبات فان جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
يتهم وزاره الدفاع بالتعتيم على حجم
الخسائر في اوكرانيا والاحجامع عن نقل
الحقائق الى اعلى الهرم
تشير تقديرات الاستخبارات الروسيه الى ان
عدد القتلى والجرح الروس وصل الى 110 الف
عنصر حتى فبراير الماضي غير ان ارقام
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لا تشمل ضحايا الحرس
الوطني او عناصر فايكنر او المقاتلين
الشيشان الوثائق كشفت ايضا اعتقاد
المخابرات الروسيه بان قوات بلادها
المتنوعه المنتشره في اوكرانيا تصرفت
احيانا وفق اهداف متعارضه ما زاد من تعقيد
الجهود العسكريه الروسيه
تقول نيويورك تايمز ان التسريبات الاخيره
تكشف عمق الاختراق الامريكي للحكومه
الروسيه بشكل شبه تامن تقريبا كما تظهر ان
خرق الاستخبارات الامريكيه يمكن ان يحتوي
على مواد اكثر بكثير
الكرملين بدوره نفم وصفها بتقارير وانبات
تداولتها وسائل اعلام غربيه حول ذلك
الصراع بين اجهزته الامنيه والعسكريه
الناطق باسم شكك في مصداقيه تلك الوثائق
وفي استيعاب القائمين عليها لجوهر ما يحدث
داخل روسيا على حد قوله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات